planus et à suresnes un jeune marocain
sur suicide après avoir grièvement
blessé une jeune fille et son frère le
premier tour des municipales pas de vote
sanction contre le gouvernement de
kerser gagnant wars auront chirac pour
les plus grandes villes la force verte
les écologistes 13 à négocier à gauche
comme à droite
leur père s'est vu par brice lalonde
secrétaire d'état à l'environnement
élections locales en allemagne fédérale
à camouflet pour le chancelier kohl prix
en ciseau entre l'extrême droite et la
gauche
le juge et le commissaire la sphère
jobic est elle politique confrontation
violente à nanterre entre le commissaire
jobic et le juge
aya madame monsieur bonsoir il est deux
heures de l'après-midi dans le soleil à
suresnes les jeunes du lycée paul
langevin vont rentrer en classe
toutacoo fusillade une jeune fille et
son frère s'effondre le tireur retourne
son pistolet contre lui et se tuent
coûte 100 coups de folie règlement de
compte familial
l'enquêté ouverte sur place and gas
burget bruno gex le corps de samir du
leem gisant à terre dans la cour du
lycée paul langevin
c'est ici que le drame a eu lieu aux
alentours de 14 heures alors que les
cours venait de reprendre sa mire de
l'image est de 25 ans d'origine
marocaine a fait irruption armé d'un
pistolet à grenaille et tiré plusieurs
coups de feu blessant grièvement son
frère et sa demi-soeur samir du leem a
ensuite retourné l'armé contre lui se
tourne d'une balle dans la tempe
ce que j'ai vu c'est qu'il était par
terre labrèche partie la batterie trop
horrible à voir
atteint de deux balles dans la tête l'un
des deux jeunes gens est décédé ce soir
à l'hôpital du kremlin bicêtre l'autre
toujours dans un état critique à
l'hôpital foch de suresnes à l'origine
du drame un différend portant sur les
fréquentations de la jeune soeur ilham
ben ali âgé de 20 ans élève de bts au
lycée langevin elle côtoyait un jeune
français ce qui aurait déplu à sa mère
de l'île municipal 89 en piste pour le
second tour les listes doivent être
déposées avant demain soir minuit
à condition bien sûr d'avoir recueilli
10% au moins au premier tour tractations
et marchandages vont donc bon train à
gauche pierre mauroy appelé aujourd'hui
à la fusion ou désistement en faveur de
la liste la mieux placée le pc parle lui
de mobilisation pour l'union la plus
large contre la droite à droite pas de
consignes nationales pour le moment on
sait que dès hier soir l'opposition
rejeté l'union composé par le front
national qui c'est l'une des
caractéristiques du premier tour
d'hyères le front national a conforté
ses positions dans certaines places
électorale autre phénomène autres
arbitres pour le second tour la percée
des écologistes on y reviendra dans un
instant mais voyons d'abord avec bruno
roger petit la carte des surprises du
scrutin d'hier
dominés nous n'oublions pas par un taux
d'abstention record pour ce type
d'élection
de gauche à droite de droite à gauche
rares sont les villes à avoir basculé de
gauche à droite
l'udf enlève au ps alençon angoulême où
triomphent l'ancien ministre georges
chavanes et prend sartrouville au parti
communiste
pour sa part le rpr s'empare de
montbéliard au détriment du ps
de droite à gauche le ps conquiert
nantes où jean marc ayrault reprend la
ville au rpr les socialistes sont
également vainqueur du rpr de l'udf à
chambéry vandoeuvre les nancy et
sotteville-lès-rouen
le second tour s'annonce prolifique en
duel spectaculaire à blois
jacques lang tentera de porter
l'estocade à pierre sudreau à dunkerque
michel delebarre et claude prouvoyeur en
découdront dans le port à lille le rpr
alex türk tentera de bouter hors du
beffroi pierre mauroy
au havre le maire communiste andré
duroméa affrontera
à nouveau antoine ruche mac son éternel
ennemi à cannes
anne marie dupuis voudra défaire le
hussard de l'udf michel mouillot enfin à
paris dans le 20e
didier bariani et michel charzat se
livreront un duel à couteaux tirés avec
comme arbitre jean marie le pen oui pour
le second tour une centaine de villes de
plus de 30 mille habitants sont donc en
ballottage un car celui de mulhouse
résume bien les particularités de ces
municipales 89,4 listes vont rester en
piste
arbitre de la situation le fonds
national qui a réalisé hier un score
important et aussi les verts qui comme à
strasbourg ont ramassé plus de 10% des
suffrages à mulhouse aujourd'hui claire
chazal à mulhouse plus d'un habitant sur
cinq est immigré
c'est dans ces quartiers pauvres que les
turcs ou les maghrébins refusée par la
suisse ou l'allemagne s'installe
lusine proche de peugeot leur donne du
travail le front national a trouvé là sa
terre d'élection une audience très forte
plus de 20% et surtout extrêmement
stable il fait jouer plus que jamais les
thèmes de l'insécurité du chômage
gérard frôlait le candidat front
national s'affirme sans mollir
le défenseur du mulhouse des clochers et
non des mosquées un langage parfois
dures selon certains une campagne dure
on dit ce qu'on pense c'est tout moi je
suis pour la priorité logements hlm où
la priorité de l'aide sociale municipale
français d'abord
je pense que droite place au marché
également c'est pour les mulhousiens
d'abord si le fait de privilégier les
miens est les français ou les
mulhousiens d'abord c'est être dur et
bien jamais dieu en ces conditions c'est
vrai mais une autre sensibilité brouille
le jeu électoral à mulhouse
celle des écologistes des amoureux du
verre surtout séduit par la personnalité
d'antoine waechter de pollution
particulier
oui surtout si vous descendez l'avenue
du président kennedy
là où je vais marcher pour aller chez
mon ma peur c'est dingue
ainsi s'élargit de plus en plus l'espace
politique entre la droite et la gauche
traditionnelle
les mulhousiens pour qui la sauvegarde
de l'identité alsacienne prime cherche
d'autres choses
mais la force du front national risquent
bien de balayer le maire sortant udf
joseph klifa au profit du socialiste
jean marie bockel
les écologistes sont bien décidés à être
le gravier dans la chaussure des partis
pour reprendre l'expression de leur tête
de liste à toulon des partis et aussi
des conseils municipaux puisque les
résultats du premier tour d'hier font
déjà participé leurs élus à la gestion
de villes comme rennes rouen nancy ou
albi la force verte est désormais un
phénomène national son histoire pascal
binet les verts arbitres les verts
courtisés
une revanche pour un parti pas tout à
fait comme les autres 74 question de
style question de langage le professeur
rené dumont détonne verdict des urnes
1,3 pour cent seulement aux
présidentielles les miltants d'alors
porte volontiers barbe et cheveux longs
manifestation contre le nucléaire ici
créé smallville il ya 12 ans répression
musclée l'écologie n'échappe pas à la
marginalité 81 présidentielle lalonde
succéda dumont 3,9 pour cent c'est mieux
mais c'est peu 83 municipal
malgré quelques percées local remarqué
les verts n'obtiennent que 150 élus en
france
l'aspiration mieux vivre a toujours
autant de mal à se traduire dans les
urnes
tchernobyl puis acide pollution par le
plomb menaces sur l'ozone l'écologie
devient thèmes de société avant d'être
érigée en thèmes de campagne 87 les
verts réunis en congrès décide de garder
leur autonomie ni à droite ni à gauche
88 un nouveau visage pour les verts
antoine waechter
cheveux courts veston-cravate presque 4%
présidentielle colloques conférences
internationales les politiques se
mettent à miser sur la défense de
l'environnement
les verts eux savent qu'ils ne pourront
agir efficacement qu'au sein des
conseils municipaux 12 mars 89
non content de s'imposer dans l'est les
verts conquiert la façade atlantique aux
13% de strasbourg et mulhouse répondait
en ce 15 % obtenus hier à lorient
quimper ou rennes
comment rsa les partis traditionnels
doivent désormais compter avec le
partenaire vers antoine waechter en tout
cas l'annoncé par tous ces candidats
auront dépassé les 10%
ils se maintiendront au second tour on
le voit la montée en puissance des verts
en france a été plus tardive - organiser
aussi qu en allemagne
brice lalonde bonsoir on vous reconnaît
on vient de vous voir vous étiez le
candidat écologiste donc aux
présidentielles de 80 vous êtes
maintenant membre du gouvernement rocard
chargé comme il se doit de
l'environnement alors cette poussée du
vote écologiste que l'on constate un peu
partout en france
à quoi l'attribuez-vous à cette prise de
conscience des problèmes de
l'environnement ou bien un refuge du
vote disons au stylo réticents aux
partis traditionnels
moi je crois surtout que les français
veulent qu'on s'occupe davantage de
l'environnement
je vois ce vote comme extrêmement
important très encourageant d'ailleurs
pour ce que j'essaye de faire moyens
gouvernement savait que même quand on
dit vous avez dit que la france était un
peu en retard au fond c'est en france
que pour la première fois un écologiste
a été nommé au gouvernement et on a
besoin pour accompagner l'action que
nous menons sur la couche d'ozone sur le
sommet de l'année sur les déchets pas
tout ce que nous faisons aux niveaux
européen national on a besoin d'un
enracinement local
on a besoin d'écologistes qui s'occupe
de la construction de la pollution dans
les communes de lutte contre le bruit de
l'aménagement du paysage deux lots on a
vraiment besoin qu'il y a un dans chaque
commune
l'élu écologiste qui s'occupe de tout ça
mais vous brisez l'on vous êtes toujours
vert si j'ose dire je suis toujours
écologiste je crois même par mois on les
étale aussi ses limites
je suis écologiste c'est à dire que je
travaille avec la majorité
présidentielle actuellement je crois que
pour les écologistes c'est important
maintenant d'être écouté la majorité
présidentielle s'est ouverte je crois
qu'après le vote du premier tour des
municipales il faut qu'elles s'ouvrent
davantage est très important pour une
majorité d'avoir besoin d'autres ça
c'est déjà ce qu'on appelle la fait
chaud vers l'armée mais tout à fait je
crois mais quel que soit d'ailleurs le
parti je crois que les partis politiques
et la majorité présidentielle dont je
fais partie en tous les cas doit
s'ouvrir aux écologistes est donné dans
chaque commune des responsabilités aux
associations c'est très important et je
crois que pour les écologistes
maintenant à partir du moment où tout le
monde est d'accord pour considérer ces
problèmes comme très important et où le
gouvernement a déjà commencé au front
national il faut absolument que les
écologistes eux mêmes accepte également
de participer aux décisions
on n'a plus le temps maintenant de
d'attendre et je crois que ce serait
mauvais pour tous les écologistes d'être
dans une opposition stérile moi je crois
que le moment est venu qu'il participe
aux décisions et et pour la majorité
présidentielle qu'elles acceptent de
s'ouvrir à l'écologie et aux écologistes
alors quand antoine waechter vous
accusent en quelque sorte d'être un
ministre socialiste je cite les propos
qu'il a tenus tout à leurs antennes 2010
oui sa longue c'est un ministre
socialiste porte parole du ps en en
campagne électorale rien à voir avec les
verts qu'est ce que vous vous lui
répondez
mais c'est vrai que je ne suis pas
membre du parti cantonne de chirac créé
qui s'appelle les verts je crois que
entre l'écologie où les écologistes et
les parties on n en a pas besoin d'avoir
sa carte d'un parti pour être écologiste
la seule différence que j'ai avec
vestiaires moi je demande à antoine
waechter de ne pas faire de polémique
politicienne on est là pour changer la
politique les règles du jeu ce serait
très mauvais à mon élevé pour les
français et surtout pour tous les
électeurs écologistes de commencer à se
chamailler
l'important je crois c'est que la france
prenne un virage pour l'environnement et
qu'elles de peine dans toutes les
communes également laissé à londres
merci en tout cas selon antoine waechter
les négociations peuvent s'ouvrir à
droite comme à gauche c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré tout
en 2010 tout en recommandant à ses avis
de maintenir leur mise quand ils le
peuvent et déjà à lille
alex türk le rival rpr de pierre mauroy
leur propose huit places éligibles sur
sa liste du second tour
lyon paris marseille en ligne de mire
hier soir avec des résultats qui colore
fortement ces municipales 89
lyon d'abord mois michel noir 45 ans
c'était le slogan électoral du jeune
hussard du rpr assagi pondéré ému à
l'annoncé des résultats qui dès hier
soir signifie que les lyonnais changer
de règne noir c'est noir nous explique
bernard traitement ils dansent gentiment
avec sa maman il a aujourd'hui une très
bonne image
ce qu'ils considéraient michel noir
comme un jeune chien fou dans le paysage
politique lyonnais se rappelle ce soir
qu'il a quand même été ministre deux ans
qu'il a de l'expérience qu'ils
représentent pour les uns le renouveau
et pour les autres la jeunesse
les deux hommes qui s'affrontent en 1983
compte aujourd'hui six ans de plus pour
l'aca a pesé davantage que pour l'autre
un renouvellement qui s'appuie sur un
programme très précis concernant les
aspects de tous les jours de la vie de
chacun et ils concernant aussi le
développement international et le
développement économique de l'agglo en
fait michel noir kadri la croix rousse
et la ville depuis bientôt 20 ans ces
prises de positions nationales récentes
lui ont valu l'estiment des lyonnais qui
combattent l'extrême droite alors donné
un bond qui tonus à la ville j'aime
beaucoup monsieur francisque collomb
mais enfin
je suis très heureux que michel noir
soit passé je pense que c'est ado
dynamique un homme jeune équipe raclette
un peu
l'ancienne génération ce soir c'est
l'équipe noire et non pas le rpr qui
négocient la composition des listes
communes avec l'udf pour le second tour
avec patience et autorités m'a-t-on dit
la patience qui a permis à michel noir
d'attendre son heure
l'autorité qui convient à celui qui veut
changer dans la continuité vraiment bar
lui déclare forfait
il cède sa place sur la liste largement
battu hier dans le 6e arrondissement
celle du maire sortant francisque
collomb à montbard ne souhaite aucun
mandat municipal autres villes clés
marseille bien sûr marseille et le
triomphe de robert vigouroux avec près
de 40 2% des suffrages sur le nom de
celui qui l'avait exclu du ps en janvier
dernier pierre mauroy n'a plus
aujourd'hui que reconnaître que la balle
est dans le camp de robert vigouroux
groupe que vous le savez avait annoncé
avant le premier tour qu'il refuserait
toute fusion avec les listes de michel
pezet robert vigouroux ou le triomphe
d'une tactique bien particulière presque
mitterrandienne celle de la campagne en
creux roland sicard
l'air de rien robert vigouroux connaît
la musique
une campagne sans fausse note une ligne
scrupuleusement respectée le maire
sortant exclu du parti socialiste a tout
misé sur son image de gestionnaire dans
une ville où plus qu'ailleurs le pastis
politiques avaient fini par lasser les
marseillais de la marque qui s'occupent
de leur ville qui se consacrent à leur
ville c'est ce ce qui les intéresse
parce que ils connaissent l'enjeu pour
le futur les politiciens les intéressent
moins une image anti politicienne
entretenu jusqu'au bout même si une
partie des vieux routiers de la
politique marseillaise avait rallié le
camp du maire sortant
mais dimanche on a d'abord voté sur un
nom tout le travail des stratèges de la
campagne a été d'amplifier l'effet ligue
où il s'agissait de dire qu'il y avait à
marseille un homme compétent valable qui
sut découvert de secret presque
ténébreux et c'est travailler travailler
travailler pour marseille nous avons
essayé de donner une image de robert
vigouroux qui n'étaient pas constitués
parce qu'il ne parlait pas c'est un
homme qui travaille qui parlent peut
instiller une démarche qui ont fait
mouche
hier robert vigouroux arrivé en tête
dans sept des huit secteurs de la ville
une marge de sécurité suffisante pour
refuser de négocier avec michel peser le
candidat officiel du ps à marseille le
maire sortant malgré jean claude gaudin
est en bonne place pour retrouver son
bureau
en marge de la campagne inculpation
aujourd'hui d'un proche de michel pezet
inculpation dans la sphère des fausses
factures
jacques l'art dit le président de shilo
tel a été laissé en liberté
venons en maintenant à paris paris qui
reste le bastion de jacques chirac
puisque le maire sortant peut encore
dimanche prochain réussir le grand
chelem car joxe espère toujours le
mouvement de bascule dans quatre
arrondissements mais les socialistes
n'ont pas vraiment réussi au premier
tour forcé la brèche
inchy l'arabe dépouillement du scrutin
hier soir 22 12e arrondissement de paris
là où se présentaient bière joxe tête de
liste socialiste
ambiance morose chez les rozes
même si c'est un mirage mais le miracle
n'a pas eu lieu certes le ps obtient 7
ballottage meas l'arrondissement peut
éventuellement échappé à jacques chirac
malgré tout pierre georges battu dans le
12e arrondissement semble y croire
encore dimanche prochain il ya
ballottage dans cet arrondissement parce
que la droite a perdu la droite et
l'extrême droite réunies ont perdu des
voix ce qui veut dire que dans ces
arrondissements à condition bien sûr que
dimanche prochain gens de gauche les
écologistes et des gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec la politique actuelle de
la mairie de paris avait voté se
rassemble il y aura l'alternance les
abstentionnistes représente plus de 40%
dans la capitale l'attitude de ce
réservoir d'électeurs est donc une des
inconnues du deuxième tour dans le xxème
notamment où jean marie le pen se
maintient fort de ses 15 % michel rocard
lui aussi se lance dans la bagarre
parisienne demain il ira prêter main
forte aux socialistes charzat dans sa
lutte contre le sortant
bariani le premier ministre michel
rocard reprend son bâton socialiste pour
un tour de france électorales avant le
second tour
second tour qui va imposer tout au long
des semaines gilles leclair des figures
parfois complexes sur la piste
électorale comme toujours cette élection
ne manquent pas à la règle les heureux
sélectionnés du second tour rivalisent
déjà depuis ce soir pour séduire et
courtisé au sein de la gauche pas de
vrais drames si la compétition éventuel
ps pc a plutôt tourné à l'avantagé du
premier
elle devrait s'apaiser en règle générale
pour faire place maintenant à l'union à
droite quasiment même cas de figure mis
à part quelques duels dimanche prochain
à cannes par exemple en revanche de
véritable épée de damoclès pèse sur les
socialistes et l'opposition au dessus du
ps est épais et verte
au total trente et une grande ville où
les écologistes sont arbitres et peuvent
aider s'ils le souhaitent les
socialistes a gagné exemple strasbourg
saint brieuc besançon quimper
l'opposition elle ne peut non plus
ignorer les appels du pied ou bien les
menaces du front national dans près de
70 villes dans le midi hyères toulon
martic par exemple dans l'est également
strasbourg mulhouse sans oublier
le 20e arrondissement de paris mais il
n'est pas sûr loin de là que les
consignes d'un appareil politique quel
qu'il soit puisse beaucoup influencé
l'opinion
une opinion qui a démontré hier qu'elle
était décidément adultes même si bien
sûr dans chaque camp on appellera tous
les électeurs en plus se mobiliser au
second tour qu'au premier en corse à
calvi
il n'a fallu près de 16 heures pour
dépouiller le scrutin la nuit dernière
et on s'attend à de nombreux recours en
annulation
la grève de la fonction publique en
effet empêché la distribution complète
des procurations une grève qui se durcit
avec deux manifestations aujourd'hui
ajaccio et à bastia sur place françoise
joly en grève depuis trois semaines et
salariés de la fonction publique occupe
leur journée
cet après midi à bastia photo de famille
devant le trésor public
un bâtiment fermé depuis deux semaines
et là on ne plaisante plus depuis le
début du conflit toute la vie
administrative de l'île est paralysée
il n'ya plus le courrier la sécu et la
caf ont fermé leurs portes sans cadre là
c'est les impôts le trésor ont fermé
leurs portes
l'équipement se permet le personnel
municipal de bastia viennent se mettre
en grève le personnel
demain du département se mettre en grève
nous vivons une situation très difficile
pas seulement pour les grévistes mais
aussi pour la population qui se trouve
prise en otage par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui pour négocier nous disons au
gouvernement ça suffit il ne faut plus
joué avec les corses est avec la corse
il faut envoyer un négociateur ce matin
les grévistes ont manifesté en voiture à
bastia ils demandent toujours une
augmentation de leurs salaires la prime
d'insularité pour faire face au coût de
la vie une vie plus chère distille
encore ce que sur le continent
un envoyé spécial du gouvernement est
attendu dans l'île
pas pour négocier précise la préfecture
mais pour établir un rapport sur la
fonction publique en corse dans l'île ce
soir on est convaincu d'une seule chose
ce conflit est complètement dans
l'impasse mon parti a une responsabilité
globale dans le résultat des élections
d'hier j'en assume ma part c'est ainsi
que le chancelier kohl a reconnu
aujourd'hui à bonn les résultats
catastrophiques pour lui des élections
locales gagnées par la coalition de la
gauche et des verts mais aussi par les
néo-nazis
après berlin ouest l'extrême droite
siège désormais au parlement municipal
de francfort pourquoi cette résurgence
brune les explications de philippe
rochot et c'est un danger parce que je
fais qui les fascistes s'organise
maintenant on tout l'euro est aussi ont
tout le monde
m ainsi par les groupes de gauche quand
il évoque la montée de l'extrême droite
npd est républicain sont-ils néo nazis
oui répondent les députés alternatif à
berlin en ressortant la phrase utilisée
par les opposants à hitler demain il
sera trop tard
slogan des républicains l'allemagne
d'abord quand on voit les chiffres de
l'année 88
on s'aperçoit que chaque mois l'imi
l'étranger du monde entier arrivent chez
nous essentiellement pour des raisons
économiques
il est donc compréhensif de vouloir
arrêter tous les abus sur le droit
d'asile nostalgie du troisième reich
xénophobie face à la montée de l'extrême
droite la gauche et les militants de
tous les groupes pacifistes tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
les nazis dehors c'est un slogan qui
vise aussi bien le npd qui progresse
dans l'état régional de hesse que les
républicains dans un pays qui compte
quatre millions et demi d'étrangers
le patron des républicains chez eux nous
leur ancien ss faire recette quand ils
déclarent chaque turc qui est là depuis
plus de 25 ans n'a pas de souci à se
faire mais nous nous battrons contre le
droit de vote aux étrangers le vote ici
est seulement pour les allemands
les républicains ont su pourtant se
maintenir dans la légalité en
n'utilisant aucune référence au nazisme
ça n'est pas le cas du rassemblement
national de michael qu'une perquisition
et interdiction de se présenter à des
élections au siège du parti à langen les
symboles nazis sont partout visibles
son chef qui a écopé de plusieurs années
de prison et même l'auteur d'un livre
la deuxième révolution son combat en
quelque sorte je ne suis pas fasciste je
suis national socialiste je pense que le
troisième reich avait des solutions plus
efficace qu'aujourd'hui pour résoudre
les problèmes il y a des moyens sur le
plan administratif qui peuvent être
utilisés par exemple j'interdirais les
partis d'opposition et leur propagande
jeu diminuerait tous leurs moyens de
pression
tout ce qu'on fait contre nous
aujourd'hui michael kuhn jeunes
considèrent comme une victoire son
interdiction de participer à des
élections
elle traduit la peur du pouvoir et la
poussée de l'extrême droite va renforcer
le clan des 1500 néonazis d'allemagne
fédérale domaine semblable en autriche
où l'extrême droite reprend pied grâce
aux élections régionales au liban
l'armée israélienne a abattu la nuit
dernière trois membres
un commando palestinien éric perrin
trois palestiniens abattus au sud liban
alors qu'ils tentaient de s'infiltrer en
israël
le commando du front de libération
palestinien était intercepté par les
gardes frontières israéliens dans la
zone tampon qui sépare le liban du nord
d'israël
c'est la seconde tentative
d'infiltration palestinienne qui échoue
en 24 heures
la navette spatiale américaine discovery
a décollé de cap canaveral en floride
avec deux heures de retard dû à un épais
brouillard matinal
la navette avec à son bord cinq
astronautes effectuera une mission de
cinq jours
discovery doit déployer un satellite
destiné à améliorer les communications
entre l'espace et la terre
un cargo panaméen s'est échoué en baie
de st ties au large des côtes de
cornouailles
malgré des conditions météorologiques
très mauvaise vents de force 10 vagues
dépassant 11 m deux hélicoptères de la
royal navy ont pu hélitreuiller les
membres d'équipage
la sphère jobic ce double thèse d'un
règlement de comptes politique
ambiance franchement entendu aujourd'hui
à nanterre où le juge hayat venait à sa
demande
témoigner dans le procès du commissaire
ou vendredi dernier avait fait état
d'une singulière conversations privées
compte rendu rémy rock extrême tension
lorsque jean-michel agathe se présente
devant le tribunal la salle d'audience
est comblé
dans l'assistance de nombreux juges
d'instruction venus témoigner leur
solidarité vis-à-vis de leurs collègues
je demande de la façon la plus
catégorique les propos que jobic me
prête c'est un menteur d'ailleurs ajoute
le juge
on ne trouvera pas dans le dossier la
moindre trace d'investigation en
direction des milieux politique et il va
plus loin il n'en profite d'être ainsi
entendu pour la première fois par le
tribunal sur cette affaire dit il
il règne depuis le début un climat de
violence inouïe pressions intimidations
sur les témoins sur les parties civiles
est aussi celui même plusieurs lettres
de menaces de mort et d'innombrables
coups de téléphone la nuit à son
domicile depuis un an dit il
malgré une projection approcher tous les
jours j'ai peur après cet épisode qui ne
pourra pas être sans conséquence le
président foulquier reprend ces
questions méticuleuse aux uns et aux
autres sur le fond de la faire avec des
témoins soudain amnésiques d'autres qui
se contredisent ou encore se traitent
mutuellement du menteur la tâche du
tribunal ne sera pas simple prenons un
peu d'air et devant après cette
actualité un peu lourde du vent dans des
voiles bizarre qui devrait permettre à
lionel péan de conquérir le record du
monde de vitesse à la voile
son objectif 100 km heure à bord d'un
engin que nous fait découvrir jean ma
mère voilà résultat un engin à mi chemin
entre les lgv volante l'avion réaction
et le planeur pur fruit de l'imagination
humaine
ce bateau il faut bien l'appeler ainsi
utilise les techniques les plus modernes
vérins hydrauliques carbone et fibre
sainté
sika haute définition employés sur les
avions supersoniques ajouté l'ordinateur
de bord et sept voitures bateaux de
course se pilote comme un avion mais
c'est bien un bateau il est conçu et
homologué comme tel
demain notre bateau marche à 40 noeuds
ou à 35 noeuds on peut faire homologuer
le record puisqu'il n'y a aucune
assistance entre le pilote d'abonnés
notre skipper pilote a juste la place
dans son cockpit type formule le plan de
voilure se trouve derrière lui il
manoeuvre à l'aide des instruments de
bord miracle ça marche même si l'engin
n'est pas dans sa configuration
définitive pour une longueur de 10
mètres et avec une aile provisoire de 16
m² il atteint par force 2 à 3 aisément
la vitesse de 20 noeuds pratiquement 40
km heure les 100 km 100 pour demain
c'est à dire début 90 si tout va bien
mais pourquoi pas en tout cas il paraît
qu'il s'agit d'un bateau opérait de
bresse elle vous parle de vrais chevaux
avec ses pronostics pour le prix saint
germain demain à enghien le 18 le 11 le
17 le dise le 12 le 9 le 16 et le case
dans un instant c'est laurent cabrol qui
va nous parler du temps demain demain la
journée commence sur antenne 2 à 6h45
avec roger zabel et sa fine équipe à
7h45 gérard morin recevra aux 4 vérités
non pas un homme politique mais un
réalisateur alexandre arcady pour la
sortie de son film
l'union sacrée pour ce soir votre
dernier rendez vous avec l'information
sur antenne 2 c'est avec philippe lefait
à 23h50 près votre soirée
à demain 20 heures